okay so i am recording a whole bunch of
videos because the week that thor 4
comes out i'm gonna be on a cruise and
uh i'm not going to be here so
all these theories may prove to be wrong
i mean they're my theories right i don't
care if they're right or wrong i just
like making theories and apparently you
guys love when i make theories for no
other reason to poke holes in them but
thank you by the way but uh but yeah so
this video we're just gonna throw out
this crazy ass theory that this whole
thing with gore is basically the result
of thanos right now i do want to make a
video later on that says this whole
thing is actually the result of hella
because i feel like that's actually a
more credible theory than the whole
thing with thanos but it is entirely
possible this is the case right because
they could just kind of rework
everything that goes on with gore now i
know a lot of people are kind of like i
don't know and rightfully so but thanos
had his time he had he had like the
whole first 10 years of the marvel
cinematic universe it was all building
up to thanos and i do agree there is
something just a little thin about the
idea of just everything goes back to
thanos we all love that time period in
the mcu there's a lot of nostalgia with
iron man one and two and not really i
man three but like there's a lot of
nostalgia when it comes to like those
older movies so i understand not all
folks may not necessarily like this but
i do think it's a cool idea to at the
very least have callbacks because what i
don't want in the future of the mcu is
for it to feel like everything's
disconnected so like the first 10 years
have nothing to do with what's going on
right now like i would rather that not
be the case i don't think that thanos
needs to return to some overarching
villain but i do like the idea that the
consequences of what he did had a huge
effect on the marvel cinematic universe
more than simply just what we've seen so
far so referencing the comic books those
of you guys who aren't familiar with
gore the god butcher the idea behind
gore is that he was basically a guy who
lived on a desolate world along with his
family and they were part of a nomadic
tribe that would just travel across the
world just trying to live quite
literally just trying to survive because
the world was just an exceedingly harsh
place which really begs the question how
is that world even capable of supporting
life in the first place but that's
beside the point the whole point here is
that thor and his folks were just
traveling from one place to the next
they were very much a religious group
they prayed to the gods and the idea was
that the gods would bless them with
water or if they arrived at some
destination that was lush with resources
and so on it was because the gods
blessed them with that and all that kind
of stuff right so like good things
happening was proof of god's existence
and bad things happening was proof of
god's existence kind of hard to argue
with that logic but the thing about this
is that gore actually doubted the
existence of any gods and this really
came to a head when over the course of
their journey he basically lost his
entire family due to the environment
they were in starvation or just natural
disasters or whatever the case was and
he cursed the gods and as a result of
that he was exiled from his own from his
tribe he was literally booted out now
this was really him just being left to
die until he stumbled across the bodies
of two gods one of which was null and
the other one was just a golden god
whose identity i don't think marvel's
ever revealed but what he came to
realize is that the gods do actually
exist and as a result of that he came to
realize that god simply just weren't
answering their prayers the gods were
just ignoring them and that's what led
to his hatred of the gods and so he ends
up taking the sword which came to be
known as the all black or the all black
necro sword or the necro sword or any
number of names that people call it and
went on a crusade across the universe
killing every god he could find and i
always talk about this every single time
i talk about gore the guy was amazing he
had this uh this moment where he was
basically interrogating thor and he told
thor that he tortured the god of torture
to the point that the god of torture
actually gave up his own family's
location it was nuts just how crazy gore
was i think we can all universally agree
the only reason gore was so awesome in
the comics was because he had
head tails and didn't have a nose
and if he didn't have head tails or a
nose in the comics well it would have
just taken away from the significance of
everything the comic never would have
been worth reading in the first place
that's how important the head tails and
the nose were
in sarcasm stop complaining about stupid
things so here's the thing when it came
to gore right when it came to this whole
thing my idea is this take that origin
of gore and then just wrap it up and
throw it into everything going on with
regards to thanos right we know that
like thanos over his time before he got
the infinity stones he traveled across
the universe and he had basically been
wiping out half the population of entire
worlds when he got the infinity stones
then he realized he could just do it in
one fell swoop like he could just snap
his fingers and blink out half the life
in the universe that way because as we
know thanos is a firm believer in the
philosophy
work smart not hard now having said that
is it that hard to believe that the
actions of thanos would result in any
number of people on any number of those
worlds those survivors during this whole
great big huge conflict when this was
happening
begging to their gods to save them right
like save us save us save us and
basically being ignored the entire time
only for the defeat of thanos right that
whole thing reaching the ears of
everybody else because i have to believe
when thor joined the guardians of the
galaxy and then went out into the
universe that they kept it all to
themselves
it's like one of those things like the
worst kept secret ever right like surely
everybody knows it's not that hard to
believe that in that circumstance gore
would look at everything that unfolded
and then realized people like thor exist
and by his own
you know looking around or doing his own
investigation suddenly the asgardians as
a whole exist and like zeus and the
olympians exist and all these gods that
we've never seen before exist possibly
even the gods of his own planet exist
and came to the realization the gods
could have stepped in when thanos was
doing this and they never did and as a
result of that gods don't care about
mortal people gods are just really
really crappy folks who are out there
and gore goes on a crusade to start
killing gods especially if instead of
gore's family dying as a result of
natural disasters or something like that
his family were half the people that
were chosen to be cold half the people
that were chosen by the forces of thanos
to be killed and he was kept alive
because we saw that right that scene
with gamora like when she was a little
girl and like they were splitting up the
world like half the world's population
in the most inefficient way ever and uh
and and like you had daughters like
begging for their moms and families
begging to stay together and all that
kind of stuff we saw that go down so
honestly while it would kind of be like
i mean really we're referencing thanos
again i think it's a cool idea because
it hits at this notion that the
consequences of thanos blinking out half
the life in the universe or traveling
around the universe and killing half the
life on any individual world manually
that they're the consequences for doing
that were
much further reaching than like the
collapse of an ecosystem or economies
going belly up or something like that it
was a crisis of faith for a lot of
different people not only that but it
makes gore relatable in the sense that
the question that we've all had ever
since the end of infinity war and
avengers in-game specifically in-game
and we saw the introduction of the
eternals and the celestials now we know
zeus exists in thor 4 and all these
things that we're wondering the question
that we all have is where were they what
were they doing when all of this was
happening what was zeus and the
olympians doing when half the earth's
population was being wiped out of
existence with a snap or thanos forces
invaded or something like that did they
not know that this was thanos's plan did
they have no idea that was the case why
did thor never go and contact the
olympians and let them know what was
going on and call them in for
reinforcements why didn't the eternal
step in why didn't they get involved
they were told not to by the celestials
but you would think that the celestials
roaming around believer coming to the
realization that a person with
effectively nigh omnipotence with this
jeweled glove blinking out half the life
in the universe is a problem because
maybe it affects them right like where
were all these different beings that
existed out there and if it's one of
those things where the gods wouldn't be
affected by half the universe's
population blinking out of existence
maybe they just didn't care whatever the
answer is that we're given if it's done
in the right way it would feed into the
nature of gore and our ability to look
at that and say yeah man gore's right
the gods just really don't care like
they really just didn't care if at the
end of the day thor's like where were
you guys during that whole thing and the
response to zeus is i mean it didn't
bother us i'm immortal i can't be
destroyed right we cannot die in that
traditional sense we can't be blinked
out of existence because we are forever
i'll just come right back like quite
literally thanos snapped his fingers i
turned to dust and then walked out of
that closet over there because it's
impossible to kill me like it's just one
of those things right if that's the case
and it's kind of like okay cool so like
that gives us our answer and so it would
make gore relatable in that way i'm not
saying it would be as goofy as that
explanation but i'm simply just saying
this idea that the gods wouldn't be
affected by it therefore the gods simply
don't care would feed into our
understanding of why it is that gore is
doing what he's doing so i don't know i
mean just let me know what you guys
think right i mean i really like this
theory and i like this idea again i get
that it's going back and it's
referencing thanos and again i do agree
with the idea that thanos had his time
but i do think there's something to be
said about saying these are the
consequences of what happened these are
the consequences of thanos blinking out
half the life in the universe the
consequences are not just limited to
what you saw during the events of
avengers in game there were much bigger
consequences beyond that much bigger
things that were affected by this on a
huge scale and in a big way so i'm
curious well i think it's just one of
those really really interesting ideas a
really interesting concept i'm excited
to see how they handle it in the movie i
mean it could be that gore's entire
basis is just far more basic than that
if it is i feel like it's a missed
opportunity but thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace